Here's a really important political story
that crosses the virus story.
It crosses 2020 election.
It crosses the Democratic primary storyline.
Separation of powers.
Really a lot of stories are involved here.
Democratic Speaker of the House Nancy Pelosi
is now calling for the country to vote by
mail.
Period.
Now, of course, with Corona virus raging and
ravaging the country, as we now get into the
phase of the pandemic where the daily death
toll is staggering, there are more and more
questions about what's the rest of the Democratic
primary going to look like.
But also, what's the November election going
to look like?
A bunch of Democratic primaries have already
been postponed because of the virus.
Some states have already decided they are
going to vote by mail or rather, some states
already vote by mail.
Others are trying to figure out what can they
do to get going in that direction.
But eventually we're going to get to the November
general election.
Now, I've received dozens and dozens of emails
from people saying is Trump going to try to
postpone the election in November?
Is Trump going to try to use the virus to
stay in office indefinitely?
Will it be safe to go out and vote in November?
Won't the Trump ists who don't take the virus
seriously go out and vote, whereas Democrats
who are more likely to take the virus seriously
will stay home, helping Donald Trump getting
it, helping Donald Trump to get reelected?
Well, of course, the answer is we should be
able to vote by mail.
And Nancy Pelosi is now saying that's exactly
what should happen, which is going to become
one of the biggest political fights since
impeachment.
Here is Nancy Pelosi saying it on MSNBC yesterday
in term city elections.
I think that will profit the moving to vote
by mail.
That's why we want it.
She has more resources in this third bill
that just was signed by the president to get
those resources to the states to facilitate
the reality of life is that we are going to
have to have more felt by now and hope that
we would have also some funding which was
rejected for the postal service, which is
well and implement to vote by now, as well
as implementing right now getting equipment
to where it needs to be.
So that's very clear.
She says we need to vote by mail.
The problem is, Republicans don't.
This Trump doesn't want this.
Trump actually said this week, vote by mail
is one of the package of ideas that Democrats
wanted in the stimulus bill that would hurt
Republicans.
I want to tell you this.
If you look at before and after the things
they had in their work, crazy, they had things,
levels of voting that if you ever agree to
it, you'd never have a Republican elected
in this country again.
They had things in there about, you know,
election days and what you do and all sorts
of clawbacks.
And they had things that were just totally
crazy and had nothing to do with the workers
that lost their jobs.
One of those crazy things that Democrats wanted
in the bill that would make it so Republicans
don't win is people voting by mail.
They had things, levels of voting that if
you agreed to it, Republicans wouldn't win
ever again, said Druck Donald Trump.
So they know that when more people vote, it's
not good for Republicans.
So let's talk about how this applies to the
November election.
We know Democrats are taking stay at home
orders more seriously than Republicans.
We know Democrats are taking the corona virus
more seriously than Republicans.
If that continues, if the pandemic persists
and you have to vote in person, more Democrats
are going to stay home.
And that will allow Trump ists to likely get
Donald Trump reelected because they are more
likely to be ignoring stay at home orders
if they even have them in their states.
So this is going to be a major fight.
It's good that Nancy Pelosi is bringing this
up.
This should not be controversial.
We've had absentee ballots for years.
Absentee ballots are a form of vote by mail.
Some people are able to do it because they
can justify it.
They're either going to be away unable to
vote in person for whatever other reason.
We're talking just about expanding absentee
voting to everyone.
We have the system.
They are going to argue Republicans that it's
too short notice.
We simply can't do it.
We have the systems in place.
States already have vote by mail in the sense
of absentee ballots.
We're simply saying allow everyone to get
an absentee ballot.
This is another reason why Trump wants to
open things back up if things are open.
It's harder to justify vote by mail if things
remain closed because of the pandemic.
If states are still under stay at home orders
or sort of shutdown guidelines, it is more
likely that Nancy Pelosi would be able to
get her way on vote by mail would be actually
a fantastic modernization of our election
system to switch to 100 percent vote by mail.
People don't need to go stand in line, all
bunched together, spending sometimes hours
in line voting.
Vote by mail.
It makes sense.
Trump and Republicans know it's an existential
threat for Trump's second term, so they will
do everything they can to prevent it.
But we should do it.
We'll continue to cover this and other stories
from today's show on the David Pakman show
Instagram page at David Packman Show while
you're on Instagram.
Make sure you're following me for the latest
Corona virus port updates on my Instagram
page.